we're sitting here talking people are
waiting for the beginning of season five
but you were experiencing the end of
season five yeah how's that feeling
it's not good it's not terrible it's not
a good feeling everyone wants to say is
it Bittersweet I'm like it's just kind
of bitter right now why is it so bitter
you just know this is a rarity it's like
has been lightning in a bottle and I
don't even need the success that we've
had I just mean the experience it's been
a group of actors
that are all seasoned in their own way
and many of a certain agent like no one
has drama no one has anything to prove
everyone loves loves it everyone loves
to work and loves to work hard and with
this kind of material I mean I think
we're just all aware that we're
breathing rarified air when we're here
and
you know and we're gonna miss it we're
gonna miss each other